>>> It's been nearly a week
since the evacuation order was
lifted in east palestine, Ohio
where a train carrying hazardous
chemicals derailed on February
3rd.
Three days later fearing an
explosion, authorities
controlled what they call the
controlled release of the toxic
chemicals and burned off which
created a massive black cloud
over the town and while the EPA
has tried to reassure the public
that the air and water in the
area are safe, not all residents
are convinced and they are
incredibly concerned about the
long-term potential impacts both
on the environment and economy.
Jason Carroll is in east
palestine, Ohio.
Ohio governor dewine gave an
update a short while ago.
What did he have to say?
>> Reporter: He did.
He did.
One of the headlines out of the
update from the glove New York
City -- governor, as well as
well as state health officials,
they are strongly recommending
those who evacuated and returned
home, some of those folks say
you should drink bottled water
unless further notice.
This is especially true they say
of pregnant women and women who
are breast feeding.
Also included in that are folks
who have private wells.
So this announcement just coming
out just a short while ago.
They're saying that again, most
of the contaminants have been
contained but they want to wait
for more testing to come back
from the municipal testing that
is still outstanding.
So right now in terms of the
cleanup effort, they're focused
on four waterways.
They do say that since the train
derailment and since the
controlled release, they said
now an estimated 3,500 fish have
died from 12 different species.
We spoke to a number of people
here on the ground who are
hearing about this information.
They are extremely frustrated
and quite frankly, really
worried about their safety.
The governor was asking about
that.
He said if he lived in the area,
would he feel safe being at
home?
>> I think that I would be
drinking the bottled water and I
would be continuing to find out
what the tests were showing as
far as the air.
I would be alert and concerned
but I think I would probably be
back in my house.
>> Reporter: Again, state
officials say the air quality is
safe.
They are still waiting for more
test results on the water
quality but a lot of people here
feeling very unsafe at the
moment.
>> Yeah, understandably so.
The town is inviting members of
the community to get-togethers
tomorrow.
What do we
>> From everything we've heard
here on the ground expect a lot
of fireworks.
>> Thanks so much.
Another person who's been
following this disaster closely
is consumer advocate and
environmental disaster.
The EPA has tried to assure
residents any immediate danger
has passed but about 3,500 fish
have died in Ohio's waterways
after the derailment when asked
about those deaths and reports
of people getting headaches and
sore throats.
The health director the state of
Ohio says it doesn't look like
air quality is to blame.
What do you make of all this?
>> Well, oh, my gosh.
This kind of goes to show the
delay of information that's
getting out to the people and
addressing their concerns.
Since this happened on February
3rd I've been hearing from the
communities as early as February
4th about children having
breathing issues, onset of as
muattacks, rashes, projectile
vomiting, getting evacuation
orders, not wearing where to go,
to shelter in lace.
A lot of confusion, a lot of
miscommunication if no
communication.
Here we are ten days out, and
now you're just hearing the
governor as your reporter just
stated, now there's an issue
with don't drink the water.
This is precisely what's
concerning this community
because all the information
isn't in yet.
Look, it was a train derailment.
Ten cars with a hazardous
chemical, vinyl chloride, that
was set to explode that they put
into a controlled burn, and the
information isn't all in.
So what assurance are you going
to give this community that it
is in fact safe, which has been
their concern all along.
And now we're hearing drink
bottled water.
So this is a bad situation for
this community, and they have
every right to be concerned.
And the reports go onto animals
that have died, chickens, beyond
the fish.
So this is so mismanaged.
And there's a systemic issue
going on in all these
environmental issues that aren't
being addressed, and leaders
need to show up at that town
hall and be present and hear
what's happening to that
community.
So it's very frustrating and
concerning.
>> The Ohio EPA says it's not
sure how much of these chemicals
spilled into the soil or the
water.
They also acinformationed the
cleanup of the derailment site
could literally take years.
Is this an indication that
people should not live in east
palestine, Ohio, or the
surrounding area?
>> That's exactly what the
community wants to know.
And as long as this information
isn't given to them, full
transparency whether you do or
don't know something, you leave
them in a horrible, vulnerable
position to return to an
environment that is unsafe.
And that is absolutely
unacceptable from local, state,
and any federal authorities.
Look, this community wants to
believe that the oversight is
protecting them, but we're
hearing way too many stories how
long it could be for cleanup.
We don't have all the data yet.
Don't drink the water.
Why would they want to live
there?
At this point I don't think
there's faith or trust, Jake, in
what the government agencies are
telling them.
>> You've been call on the Biden
administration to be better
about communicating with the
residents of east palestine,
Ohio, who as you know feel as
they've been left in the dark.
What should the Biden
administration, what should the
EPA do differently?
>> Show up and hear that
community, see that community,
listen to that community.
Go out there, find the dead
animals, do the testing, start
doing water testing, and being
trance parent with them.
Look, by not showing up, by not
addressing this, it's a national
train derailment with very
hazardous information, you do
nothing but create a vacuum of
an upset community, a
misinformed community, a
distrusting community, and it
adds to rumors, speculation,
losing trust and a lot of
theories.
Show up and answer their
questions, be present, act like
you care about what's going on
in your backyard in this country
and be involved and not just sit
there and give them a bunch of
misinformation.
And then you wonder why they're
frustrated.
Show up.
>> What are you expecting at the
open house, the town hall
tomorrow?
>> So right before we came on I
heard they've changed that town
hall which would be a format for
the community to ask and get
questions answered, it's been
turned into an informational
desk where you can go and get
information, of which I
understand Norfolk railroad will
be there.
So the town hall isn't going to
be as expected so I expect
there'll be even more outraged
and upset citizens who now